dude I got the coolest girl we met at a
bar dude like [__] 1972. I'm doing a
soft ticket show on Fremont Street
nobody's there to see me I just
immediately was attracted to her and was
she coming to see you or was she just
going they were just at the bar and then
one night she shot her shot well she
came into the room we were all in and
just sat on my lap you know Bunny's got
that goddamn thing on her side
Bunny's got that thing on her did you
get pricked well she wouldn't have felt
it anyways
I'm so fat I could be fully erect and
standing up and nobody no
[Laughter]
and then we ended up at the little bar
that night and and had a couple couple
of drinks and she she kissed me and we
went back to the house and man she tried
me and I was like hold on hold on hold
on hold on I need to know what you're
trying to do with your life or I'll let
you put that [__] on me and [__] my
life up